a demonstration has taken place in the  u.s city of louisville to mark a year  since the killing of 26 year old brianna  taylor  a black medic shot dead when three  police officers forced entry into her  home  using a no knock warrant ben crump the  attorney for brianna taylor's family has  praised protesters  to all of you who kept showing up  who kept showing up even when  the county attorney said they weren't  going to do nothing  and then send it over to the attorney  general of the state  and he said he wasn't going to do  nothing well guess what  y'all said y'all going to do something  and that's why  everybody knows brianna taylor's name